President Biden calling for a Crackdown
on guns but not on the criminals who
actually commit the crimes
they'll accelerate and intensify this
work to save more lives more quickly
first as executive order helps keep
Firearms out of dangerous hands ban
assault weapons ban them again do it now
enough do something do something big I
laid out of my budget
that we invest more in safer communities
and expand access to Mental Health
Services for those affected by gun
violence
Congressional Republicans
[Applause]
should pass my budget instead of calling
for cuts in these services or defunding
the police or abolishing the FBI
but will his plan actually stop crime
Biden's big speech said nothing about
our country's lacks bail laws a study
found California suspects released
without having to post bail went on to
commit other crimes they were 90 percent
more likely to commit felonies and the
offenses were 200 percent more likely to
be violence okay you know um I'll start
with you Jessica the truth is that the
the the president keeps talking about
the assault weapons ban and you know it
was in 93 I believe and and everything
about that in terms of the studies
indicate that it really didn't make a
big difference but does he really think
that criminals and gun dealers and gang
members uh the ones who are actually
committing the crimes going through the
legal channels to buy guns no but there
is a part of it which I think should
help or certainly the idea would help
about improving the reporting on guns
and ammunition that's stolen in transit
so people who do bad things like kill
people also might steal things so maybe
they are doing that I don't think that
there's anything certainly considering
the fact that we now have had bipartisan
gun legislation
um that's objectionable in this I
understand if you want to Pivot and say
this isn't addressing the issue of
cashless bail and things like that and
what these prosecutors in Philly and La
New York City are doing Etc
um but everything in here is good and
the assault weapons ban which was from
94 to 2004. there is evidence that it
did some good and I think it's worth
exploring again I understand Republicans
are not going to budge on that but in
the meantime the president is making
good on his promises to do as much as he
can he still wants Congress to do more
for him but I think that any Democratic
president would do this and I mean there
are a lot of gun control Advocates who
think that frankly he's not even going
as far as he possibly could it's the
closest we can get to Universal
background checks well the truth is the
increase on the background checks pretty
much puts us at the place of of the
universal background check but one of
the things that that Jessica that she
mentioned was when you kill people you
steal things too and the truth is that
you get bailed out whether you kill them
with a legal gun or an illegal gun but
the truth is statistically it's not if
you leave out cities like Chicago and
Detroit where people are running around
with illegal guns America instead of
being one of the highest countries in
terms of mortal gun crimes is one of the
lowest so what is the point of making
the illegal gun owners go through the
ringer right
he has this entire executive order he
doesn't say gangs once he doesn't say
bail once when this guy does everything
he can to not talk about the actual
issue I looked at this thing last year
he did remember this big gun legislation
that was bipartisan that was the first
time in 30 years well I just printed it
and read it and it's just a bunch of
Band-Aids and the new executive order is
just the same Band-Aids that they ran
out last year remember last year they
were going to go after ghost guns and
then they wanted to do more commercials
and then they said I'm going to spend
money to develop anti-crime strategies
wasn't it his idea to come up with a
strategy and now this new one is
basically you're going to have mayor
Pete look after ghost guns on the trains
it's all a bunch of Band-Aids and people
are sick of it you know what could
really do a lot recording a gun ban you
know what could really do a lot more
this is what I support okay under Donald
Trump they prosecuted federal gun
charges at a pretty high level and those
prosecutions went up every year Joe
Biden comes in and federal gun
prosecutions have gone down why is that
he talks a big game he doesn't back it
up you know Greg one of the things that
I did when I was looking at the stats
out of Chicago was to try to get the
stats from the feds from the United
States Attorney and from Polk County
Cook County basically told me to mind my
own business okay they were not
interested in providing gun prosecution
numbers nor were they interested in
identifying those who were released
without bail who had guns so Biden
doesn't explain how this executive
orders keeps guns out of the hands of
the criminals who are LED out of jail
well right I mean to your earlier uh
point there is there's a country within
a country that has insane gun crime
right right a specific country within a
country but it's bidens people these are
liberal Mayors in Liberal cities that
are having rampant gun crime you can say
oh but it's in a it's a red State
doesn't matter it's in these cities so
it's a country within a country but
instead he's punishing the entire
country somehow exempting
not saying gangs not talking about I
mean let's face it it's almost all gangs
handguns people getting released on the
street they get the gun confiscated they
know they're going to get another one
you know you imagine all a normal person
wants is you know a safe life that's
what everybody wants Democrats even you
Jessica would like a safe life and what
is safe you want to fence around your
house you want protection for your
family you want law enforcement there to
deal with things that you can't deal
with in all of those three Basics have
come under attack I'd say in the last I
don't know decade they've been mocked
offense is a border right uh protection
for your family is just the Second
Amendment uh last no cops and then he
has he has the cojones or what's left of
his cojones to say it's Republicans
defunding the police you guys were
shouting from the rooftops almost
literally during riots so don't so the
fact is we're we're kind of watching an
unraveling right now and we're
desperately trying to pull it back in
and they're they're refraining Remains
the Same no matter the situation their
rules Target the law-abiding they don't
Target the violent criminals it's almost
as if they want not status quo but
status chaos because that way as long as
we're consumed by crime we can't go
after them so why else would why else
are they treating this so lightly
they're not these are not issues this
does not solve anything Lord it doesn't
solve anything yeah
that's the people did that yeah but but
Democrats go to Dana yeah yeah of course
sorry all right Dana the truth is that
Biden keeps claiming that the
Republicans are pushing to defund the
police ignoring ilhan Omar Ayanna
Presley Corey Bush the whole group of
them and he also ignores the fact that
when he had the house and the Senate and
the oval he didn't do anything for gun
uh uh laws and he's about they're also
starting to roll out this talking point
that the Republicans want to defund the
border patrol yeah that's like though
that's coming as well so I think people
see right through that but Republicans
have to be ready to argue back on the
mayor's because they know where the
media is this on this especially when it
comes to covering the Border they are
not one person I always follow on gun
issues is Charles cook over at National
Review his headline is if Biden's
background check executive order has the
teeth he says it does it'll be illegal
yeah that's probably true right but what
does this get President Biden it gets
him another point to go out there and
campaign if he is going to campaign in
2024 to say I put forward additional gun
background check executive orders and
the Republicans are against it they want
your kids to be killed and then it'll go
to the courts and the courts will it'll
be and that's where it will sit because
he knows it's illegal just like student
loans just like the eviction moratorium
but he puts it out there and now the
Republicans are having to fight back not
only in the courts but on the campaign
Trail yeah politically amazing all right
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now